what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is a channel
where i help you break into data science
and grow your skills in the field this
is another video in my r
tutorial series and it's going to be my
second video in a series covering the
tidy models suite of packages
there's carrot that's an entirely
separate package and framework for
dealing with machine learning problems
tidy models on the other hand is an
entirely separate
suite of packages designed for tackling
all the different phases of a machine
learning problem
so in the previous video on tidy models
we had just gotten done training a
logistic regression
and a random forest using the training
set we had constructed
from the german credit data set now we
didn't do anything crazy here we didn't
do a whole lot as far as tuning of hyper
parameters is concerned
and we haven't really evaluated how well
we've done
for the most part at least you're given
this confusion matrix as far as the
training set is concerned
but these fits have not yet
seen the test set in any capacity so the
first thing we're going to do here
is use the yardstick package from from
tidy models
to just evaluate the performance and see
how well we're doing based on our
metrics of interest
so if all that sounds interesting to you
take one moment to smash the like button
for the youtube algorithm
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and hit the notification bell so
you never miss an update
and then lastly if you would like to
support this channel
i'll have links in the description of
the video to my patreon account my
paypal account
and crypto wallet addresses your support
is greatly appreciated
oh and of course this script is
available on my github repository as
well that's also in the description
without further ado let's get started
all right so the very first thing that
we're going to need
in order to use any of the functionality
from the yardstick package to see how
we're doing
is we need a data frame that has two
columns in it
we're going to need the source of truth
so the actual
labels and we're going to need the
predictions
so for instance here i want to see how
the random forest
performs on the test set so what i'm
going to do here is start with the test
set
extract the class variable as our source
of truth
and then i'm going to pipe that to using
the bind calls function
the predictions from the random forest
when we apply that algorithm to the test
set
so you see what we're doing on the
inside we have this predict function
you can either have that return the
class predictions
or probabilities it's going to default
to just returning the
class predictions so
that those predictions are getting bound
to the class
then we end up with this nice looking
simple class with predictions data frame
here
where we got class is the source of
truth pred underscore class
is the prediction all right so now that
we have a data frame
in the format that we need the next
thing that we have to do here is
actually define
what metrics we're interested in and
what we want to report here
so the metrics i'm interested in getting
here are accuracy
sensitivity specificity and positive
predictive value
now i went through the definitions to
these very
thoroughly in my carrot tutorial series
so i'm just going to gloss over them
a little bit here accuracy is the
percentage of the time that we're making
a correct guess
and then the rest of these are going to
be more class specific
so pick one of the two classes honestly
it's
pretty arbitrary but typically we want
to go with the one that's less
frequent and define that as the event
class so sensitivity
is going to be of the event class what
percentage of the time
is the model correctly identifying those
so in our case here of our subjects
which are bad credit risks
how often is our model correctly
identifying those bad
credit risks specificity is going to
apply to the other class
so for our good credit risks how many
times is or what percentage of the time
is our model correctly identifying
good credit cases for positive
predictive value you basically have to
invert the definition of sensitivity
so we want to know of the times
that our model is predicting somebody to
have bad
credit what percentage of the time do
they
actually have bad credit you see the
distinction there
so these are the metrics that we're
interested in these are pretty
standard summary metrics as far as
classification problems are concerned
and the way that we're going to do this
is by using this metric set function
so the metric set function is a little
bit counter-intuitive at first all it's
going to do
is essentially return a function that's
going to report
these different metrics pretty
straightforward
uh one thing i will point out though is
you'll notice i'm putting this yardstick
alias in front of sensitivity and
specificity
or sense and spec as they're called here
and the reason i'm doing that is because
the read r package
has functions also called sense and spec
so if the radar package is in your
namespace
it can happen sometimes that the metric
set function is going to throw you some
weird errors
so i'm just going to be careful throw
this alias here in front
and that way we're going to be safe and
the function's going to work
so i use this function lowercase metric
underscore set
to create this new object in camel case
metric set which is essentially just a
function that i've
that i've programmed to return these
metrics
now we're going to take this thing for a
spin and see how we do
so for the first argument i'm going to
pass in the data frame we created
earlier
specify which column is the source of
truth and which
column has our predictions
now i absolutely hate this syntax but it
is what it is
how it learns which of the two classes
represents the event case for
sensitivity is you specify
first or second so if i just run
the levels for this class with
predictions data frame
on and look at this class variable here
you notice bad is the first class that
shows up here
therefore event level first specifies
bad as the event class so
it's terrible syntax but whatever it is
what it is i guess you get used to it
and so we end up with our with our
results here so the accuracy
not bad 74.3 percent the sensitivity is
horrible
the specificity is outstanding and the
positive predictive value
honestly i think is pretty good in the
real world
if you get results like this it's really
going to depend on your specific case
this may not work for you at all you may
want to maximize specificity
at the expense of of uh or sorry
you may want to maximize sensitivity at
the expense of
specificity you met positive predictive
value could be the most important thing
again it all depends on your specific
problem
this could be perfectly reasonable for
your problem or it's completely
unreasonable but it all depends
on your individual use case what i will
say is having this kind of imbalanced
uh sort of set of results where
sensitivity is really low but
specificity is really high
that's incredibly common in these in
these types of problems where we have a
really imbalanced
uh response variable and in fact this
problem gets worse and worse
the more imbalanced the response
variable is
however there's a number of ways that we
can try and correct for that type of
problem
and the first way that we can try to do
that is by either down sampling or up
sampling
so if you've seen my carrot series you
already know the definitions of these
terms
but i'm going to go through them again
for this series too
so the goal of both down sampling and up
sampling
is to correct for this problem that we
have in the response variable
where it's imbalanced so specifically
here
70 of the rows are coming from credit
risk good
but only 30 of the rows are from credit
risk bad
so you see how there is more than double
as many
good class rows as bad class rows
so down sampling is one way that we can
correct for this
where what we do is we're basically
removing this extra forty percent and
we're sampling from the two classes in
equal proportions
so again we're only using sixty percent
of the training set because we're
eliminating forty percent of it
that's one approach the other approach
is
up sampling where we basically over
sample from the minority class
that's going to involve just throwing
duplicates into the training set
but it's just in the way that we can
handle this problem and
there's not a hard fast rule for one of
these is better than the other
you might just have to try both and see
which one is going to get you better
results
and so how we're going to do this is
we're going to add another step
to a recipe so i'm just going to define
as usual a recipe with the formula class
in terms of all the variables in the
data set
the input data is training set processed
now that's the data set or the training
set specifically
that's already gone through a whole
bunch of recipe steps that we conducted
before
things like the k nearest neighbors
imputing for missing data
the near zero variance elimination all
that's already happened
and this data set is the output of it
i'm just
using that data set in every step from
here on out
and so i'm creating a new recipe with
that data set as an input
and we're adding one more step to that
recipe
where we're using this step down sample
function from the themis
uh package now for themis
this is another one that you're going to
have to call separately you can't just
call library tidy models from the get go
and i do recommend including the alias
at the beginning here because this is
another one that i've seen
trip you up with weird error messages so
the under ratio argument here is going
to specify the exact
ratio that we want between the minority
and the majority class
so that's a little bit flexible and you
can tweak that
now as far as skip equals true is
concerned
the reason this is specified is because
if we're using this recipe for another
data set
namely the testing set we don't want to
apply this step
and the reason for that is down sampling
and up sampling should only be applied
to your training set
so this is a default so you don't even
necessarily have to specify this
but i'm going to point it out here
because it really is an important thing
now that that step has been or that
recipe has been defined
let's move on to actually combining
these things into one cohesive workflow
now think of a workflow as a container
for all the various different objects
we've been working with that provide all
the information for fitting and
predicting from a model
you've noticed we have a lot of objects
that have been floating around
we have the training and testing sets we
have these recipe objects we've created
we have models we have model fits
and very quickly you can get overwhelmed
by all these things that are floating
around
well a workflow just think of that as a
container for all these various things
so that we can work with one object at a
time instead of
like 50 different objects so what i'm
going to do here for my
random forest is i'm going to just
create a
a random forest model object the same
way that we did before
the one thing that i'm going to do
that's different here is
for the m tri hyper parameter i'm going
to pass to that
art to that argument uh this tune
function
and now we're going to see that uh in
the next tutorial
what that's basically telling the random
forest here is
don't worry about the tuning for now
we're going to do that step
later same things before with setting
the classification mode and the random
forest engine
and then i'm going to create this uh
this workflow
starting with the workflow function
think of that completely analogously to
like
gigi the ggplot function where you call
that function and then you add a bunch
of things to it
it's the same sort of idea so we're
going to add that down recipe that we
created before
and we're going to add the model that we
just created here
now after that we can use that workflow
and use that to fit
to the the process training set
that way that recipe that we created
before with the down sampling
all that gets baked to the training set
and you have a training set for which
those steps are truly applied to
so we can go ahead and just get a
performance update and see how well
we're doing
we scroll down here i'm doing
essentially the same steps that we did
before
creating the source of truth and the
predictions running the exact same
metric set that we defined before
and naturally we see that we have a
little bit more balance
of a result set sensitivity and
specificity are
almost equal but we have a massive drop
in accuracy
so i don't necessarily like these
results more than i did the last one
but i can't stress enough that it all
depends on your specific use case
in your case it may be beneficial to
have these things be as close to each
other as possible
like it's unacceptable to have an
imbalanced
result set in which case even though
accuracy is lower
these results may even be preferable so
again it all depends
i'm going to leave you guys there in the
next video we're going to go through
actually tuning the hyper parameters
that we said we were going to later
creating an roc curve and then lastly
stacking a whole bunch of different
methods together and combining
predictions
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it
smash the like button leave me a comment
down below
maybe tell me if you like tidy models
more than carrot
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data